is there anything you remember now looking back on
it ah yes here was a bit of wisdom that I gleaned
on one of these trips that I wouldn't have known
otherwise is there anything you can point to and
say ah that piece of wisdom or no was it just
kind of a feeling of wisdom no I think it was
just more of just a different mindset it was
like just a different level of Consciousness
that when I was in that place everything made
sense so it's like it was all and it's like
the funny thing about hallucinogens is like a
lot of the stuff you forget it's like you're
here and then it like leaves you and that's
why people keep oh you know I need to go do
another Retreat I need because it's like
I know it was great and I know I learned
a lot yeah I just don't remember anything I
learned yeah and you take some of it with you
you'll take like one or two things and then
the rest is forgotten and um so that's what
it was it was like like in an example was like
I always would walk away with this feeling of
like I need to be a better person like it
would crush my my ego and Crush my my pride